-I want to say spoiler alert
but the reality is, like,
nobody really knows
at the end of the last season of
"Stranger Things"
and, obviously,
your beloved character.
It's actually not quite clea
if you're dead or not, right
So, I imagine if you know,
you can't tell us.
Right?
-Yeah.
-That's fair.
Do you -- But do you know?
-Okay.
I knew this would come up.
This is the great thing abou
doing a late-night talk show
-Yeah.
-Yeah, so, okay.
Well, here's the thing.
I always knew that Hopper
had to make a sacrifice.
Like, he's a jerk and,
like, he also needs to --
he needs to pay for that
in some way.
So he needs to do --
So, but, you know,
I thought he would make
the sacrifice,
and then the script came out
and -- Spoiler alert.
Like, you know, you don't want
to know about this stuff,
I guess turn down the --
-Yeah. But also, like,
try to keep up with
culture as it happens.
-Good advice.
That's solid advice.
-I mean, there's just very
few things we all watch,
and it would be nice
if you joined us.
-But, anyway, at the end,
you know,
the post-credit scene,
there's this thing where
it's "the American," you know?
And I was like,
"Oh, clearly I'm the American.
And then I haven't gotten
many phone calls.
I...
-Because the Duffer Brothers -
they obviously know.
-Yeah. I mean, I think they're
actually the only people
that do know.
-Gotcha. But they haven't hinted
to you at all.
-No.
-Yeah.
So you're sort of --
As an actor, you're in flu
is what you're saying.
-I mean, at this point, I am
-Yeah.
Are you going to call them
-You want to call them?
-Yeah, let's do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's what I really like
Let's show off the world tha
you got a loose one.
-I'll do one better.
Let's FaceTime them.
-Okay, great.
This is the Duffer Brothers, the
creators of "Stranger Things."
-It's ringing.
-Okay.
[ Ringing ]
-Can we --
-Are they going to, like -
Are they going to pick up
the -- Hey.
-Hey.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey, what's up?
You're on the Seth Meyers show
-Big fan.
-What do you mean, like...
What do you mean?
You're shooting it right now
-Yeah, we're shooting
the show right now.
What's up?
-Why are you calling us?
-I have a question.
I have a question.
What's up, Ross?
-Yeah, turn it over there --
-Am I -- I'll let you guys
answer to the camera,
but the question is --
am I dead?
Is Hopper dead?
-I mean, we're still
figuring it out.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Would this sweeten the pot?
-You guys are a ton of help.
Thanks.
Really wonderful work.
Good luck with Season 4.
Love you guys.
Love you. Bye.
-Very nice. Very nice gentlemen.
-Awful. Awful.
-Did you hit it off with the
when you first met?
-Yeah.
I mean, I love those guys.
They're, like -- I say this al
the time, and they hate it
That's why I
continue to say it.
But they're, like, the biggest
nerds I've ever met besides me
I mean, I'm kind of a
nerdy guy, too,
but they're just, like,
little, geeky,
"Dungeons & Dragons,"
video-game-type guys.
And so we hit it off
like gangbusters, yeah.
-And it was not originally
called "Stranger Things"
when you got involved
with the project.
-No. That was the first sort o
rift between us, actually,
'cause I loved the script
so much.
I mean, I love this show.
-It's a fantastic show.
I don't say that about --
I love the show.
So, the script is amazing,
but, originally,
it was called "Montauk."
-Uh-huh.
-And I thought that was
such a good title,
like, really strong and simple
and like one word.
And it was set in Montauk.
And then they changed it
to be set in the Midwest,
so they needed to
change the title.
And they were, like -- The
called me and they were like
"We're going to call it
'Stranger Things.'"
And I was like, "That's th
worst title I've ever heard.
It sounds like some
stupid guy going like,
"Oh, I've heard
stranger things."
Like, I mean, it sounds like
a terrible idea
for a television show.
-Yeah, yeah.
-And so I hated it.
And then I saw it in the fon
with the, like, music.
[ Vocalizes
"Stranger Things" theme ]
And it's --
And it was awesome again.
-And then you realized --
Are you willing to admit now
it's a hundred times bette
than "Montauk"?
-No. No.
-Yeah.
We were originally going to call
this show "Amagansett."
But then the network was like,
"What about 'Late Night
with Seth Meyers'?"
And I was like, "All right."
-Eh, whatever.
-What's it like -- I mean,
you know,
they've grown up,
obviously, to some degree,
since you first
start working with them.
But what's it like working
with those -- you know,
a super-talented cast of kid
you have on the show?
-Uh, it's a nightmare.
-Yeah.
-No, they're -- I mean,
look, they're beautiful kids
but, I mean, you --
They're -- No, but, like,
what adult male wakes up
in the morning --
like, I'm in my 40s --
and goes like,
"You know what
I want to do today?
I want to hang out with like six
15-year-olds."
-Yeah.
-And I want to see, like,
what they're like,
and, like, what they talk about,
and, like,
what they're interested in
And I want to get involved
in conversations
that they're having
about learning about themselves,
as 15-year-olds do.
I have been in some
conversations where in the -
between them -- where, in
the middle of the conversation
I just have to walk away,
'cause I'm qualified
to speak about this,
but I'm not going tell you
-Yeah. Yeah, this is
a journey you have to take
on your own.
-Exactly. I do not
want to be involved.
-"I managed to find
these answers
without the help of a
45-year-old man."
I'm so excited for you
this week, man.
-Oh, thanks man.
-It's going to be a blast.
-Yeah, I'm really excited, too
I mean, it's a dream come true
I mean, I have to --
I want to say --
I actually do want to say hi
to my mom,
because my mom is going
through some stuff right now
And she's sick, and I just -
It was something that my mom
and I would talk about
when I was a kid,
about, like, one day
hosting "Saturday Night Live."
-Oh, man.
Well, I hope she
gets better soon.
And I can't wait for Saturday.
Thanks so much for being here.
David Harbour, everybody.